hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface
and the former advisor to boris johnson
colby ranger thank you both
so much for joining us this friday let's
take a look and see what is on the front
of some of those front pages
the mail reports that though monday's
loosening of covered restrictions is due
to go ahead the spread of the indian
variant
could mean the final relaxation on june
the 21st is delayed
that's also on the front of the
telegraph which says boris johnson has
warned the indian variant could
seriously disrupt the plans in june
the sun describes the prospect of a
postponement as squeaky bug time
the times keeps it simple lock down
easing at risk
it's the big mirrors big splash as well
threat to freedom day
also on the front of the guardian which
reports on the escalation of the
israeli-palestinian violence
the express goes with an interview with
the chancellorshi sunak who says britain
can look forward to a brighter future
as the economy bounces back after the
pandemic
the ft leads with the announcement of an
investigation by the serious fraud
office into the metals businesses owned
by sanjiv gupta
and the star relays an apparent
misunderstanding between
itself and the russian government
well as i was saying we're joined
tonight by susie boniface and colby
ranger and it does really dominate all
the front pages doesn't it the boris
johnson press conference this evening
and the fact that
possibly this this uh end of june
relaxing of all the regulations may
may not be happening um colvier do you
think
given this new variant are we reopening
too soon
look i i think this is why the
government had set out such a
elongated plan you know when we all saw
it months back we thought well they're
building in a bit of fat there they've
gone ultra cautious
they've learned the lessons from last
year of being
going too soon or being too impatient
but
what it looks like is that four-week
step in between
has been quite rightly there to account
for any
changes there's always been a case of
now we we're well aware that variance
will
emerge you know we had the emergence of
the kent one that sort of kite washed
christmas but then there were there was
a south african variant that we're all
extremely worried about
because the scientists and the medical
people were saying that that
could be quite uh quite effect honestly
well it wouldn't be affected by the the
vaccines and now the indian variant
i think the issue here is that whether
we get back to freedom there's always
going to be a question
anyway was june the 21st which we seem
to be going ahead on monday in terms of
step three but step one june the 21st
no more social distancing um going back
to an inverted commas normal
the way we're being programmed and even
i know my wife said to me today i'm not
so sure i'm
overly keen to get rid of social
distancing in june i think i'm gonna
it's gonna take people a bit longer
anyway just because we say
we're going into some call some sort of
freedom is that really gonna be
the case that people will adopt it so
the freedom 21st of june
i think we've got a bit of time to see
how the indian variant plays out
i think the medical people and the
scientists are quite rightly telling us
to be cautious the government has time
to see the data as it emerges
but i think actual normality won't be
about june the 21st it'll be how long it
takes us
to live with the virus in the background
of our lives
and susie i mean do you feel a little
bit like that i mean i i know i
certainly felt as soon as the lockdown
as soon as there were any lifting really
quite excited but now i sort of think oh
well you know
next monday thing's going to change you
know at the end of june things will
change but more there's
it's not really in the calendar as a
massive highlight anymore i mean
are you really marking off the days
until you can go indoors in a pub
not really it's sort of a combination of
uh excited and cautious at the same time
but what you've got here is we need to
just remember that this is not a
britain only issue you know we want to
release on may the 17th
june 21st or what what's boris johnson
going to say this is a pandemic
it's global at the end of this year
there may be a billion people worldwide
who are vaccinated
mainly in the richest parts of the world
that leaves six
billion people entirely unvaccinated
and that is a huge reservoir for the
disease to circulate
for new uh strains to arise and then to
arrive
in those countries that have been
vaccinated potentially
with the ability to escape some of the
vaccines and the issue with the indian
variant
is firstly that because it's more
transmissible that may mean according to
members of sage that published today
it may mean 10 to 20 000 hospital
admissions
a day they reckon and at the height of
the pandemic it was only just over 3
000 so that would be really seriously
bad even though many of us are
vaccinated there are those who can't and
those who haven't been vaccinated
and they mean that there's enough of
them that it could be serious
problems with hospital admissions and
the other issue is what i agree with
what culver said i was
happy when the news or road map was
produced
that it looked like the prime minister
and the government had learned from
their mistakes last year
and i was relieved that they were so
much more sensible with the way they
were doing it and of course
it may still work out hopefully but
what's been hugely disappointing is the
two weeks it took to close the borders
to indian travelers or travelers from
india
even though pakistan and bangladesh had
roughly the same
rates of illness as india and they
closed
travel from those countries on april the
9th it wasn't done
for india until april the 23rd that's 14
days
in which the borders were left open
again
how many times has that got to happen
for those running the country to realize
that closing them too late is too late
we've also got an issue with
self-isolation payments being so
incredibly low because rishi sunai
refuses to raise them and they mean that
only about 11 percent of people properly
isolate
and despite what the prime minister said
today about very tough quarantine rules
being in place
those quarantine rules are so not tough
that if you have traveled from a redless
country and you are asked to quarantine
you have to no one else in your
household has to they can all skip down
the road and happily infect other people
and there's nothing to stop that
happening even if they can enforce the
quarantine which of course they're not
doing a lot of the time
so we've got a huge number of issues and
actually controlling the infection rate
and it seems that
there is still unfortunately some ways
in which we haven't learned the lessons
it's about time we did a potential i
mean do you think
that's a fair point that that there was
so much criticism of the government
at the very beginning wasn't there that
that they hadn't acted quickly enough in
the advice given
i mean do you think it was an error not
not to restrict
travel uh great to deal faster to places
like india
i think there's a lot that the
government's trying to grapple with
about the international element and i
completely agree with susie
about you know let's not forget that
first word global pandemic
and so far a lot of the emphasis has
been on nation states dealing with it
internally and you some you can become a
bit inward
looking in terms of saying well we've
got it under control
we've got our thankfully the death rates
down the infection rate down
therefore we're all right and people's
behavior starts to become a bit more
relaxed
as well but it is a global issue and
that transmission from country to
country
and that's where now all countries need
to work together about how they're going
to manage
these the data the awareness the rules
regulations and there's going to be
probably a lot more
collaboration at an international level
to manage
when we see spreads and um real surges
happening in different parts of the
world so
i think there's another stage of this as
we go forward because i've been saying
last year was year zero of this pandemic
this year is probably where the first
world
gets to vaccinate itself but then we've
got you know
the other parts of the world the poorer
parts of the world the third world with
the
african continent which we don't talk
about that much about what's been going
on there in terms of covet
and as we've seen what's been happening
in india and south america as well
these countries and these areas will
take much longer to get to the stage of
vaccination than managing
uh kovitz so there's plenty of time
to go in how we need to manage this and
we will not
as a country be out of this unless all
of these countries
are in a safer place and then i think
that's where the governments have to
work together
in terms of being agile in dealing with
transmission internationally and briefly
susie it is a balance isn't it
for the government because you know
these restaurants these bars
they've held on for as long as they can
yes that many of them have managed to
have outdoor spaces but
a lot of the ones that are indoor only
have not been able to trade at all for
over a year and the prime minister's
trying to juggle isn't he
he wants the country to be safe but
equally there are many businesses
who are saying if you if we don't open
up very soon we are going to go under
yeah and many already have and there
were ways around this which were being
looked at at the start of the pandemic
including some stimulus payments to
every individual
like a very temporary universal basic
income which might have got us over some
of these issues
and would have probably worked out
cheaper than giving billions of pounds
to businesses
who then paid it out and shared
dividends to their to their shareholders
so there are you know there are other
things that could have been done
but this is where we are now this is
what we're looking forward to
and like kelvin says this is just the
start of what's going to be happening
and unfortunately we still seem to be
relying to some extent
on the sun on page four they're saying
we are going to reopen still
on may the 17th but we want people in
the areas of high infection
to think twice quote unquote about going
out to the pub
well at the same time the sun's
reporting you know huge um
preparations to sell huge amounts of
beer and so on and so forth
businesses want to sell and they want to
reopen and people want to try to get
back some kind of normal
but relying on people to use their
common sense
has probably helped a lot of us over the
past year
but it hasn't stopped two waves of the
virus
so saying we're going to reopen but you
know everyone just be a bit cautious
it's not going to work there's got to be
something more definitive than that
going on
okay susie and colbir thanks very much
for now
got a short break but coming up could we
be any more excited
to tell you about the friends reunion
join us after the break
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now susie boniface
and cool via ranger and susie you've
picked out for us uh sorry in the sun
angela rainer
she's saying that she might have voted
for boris johnson
yes what she's actually doing although
it you know it kind of is presented as
you know what i voted for him last week
you know guys
what she's actually just done is talk
about uh when she was 18 years old and a
young single parent
she might well have voted for the for
the politician who promised to be as in
her words a bit
spicy um and throwing a hand grenade and
shake things up a bit but this is kind
of part of
the labor strategy i think of trying to
show they understand why people voted
for boris johnson
and it will move on at some point to
saying that was a daft idea wasn't it
guys
but but does it diminish kierstama
uh it makes him look uns it references
the fact that he's not spicy
uh that he's a bit more maybe bland a
bit more semolina
i don't know um i haven't thought of
what kind of food stuff kierstarma might
be like but i don't think
it's spicy okay we can certainly think
about that over over the next half hour
or so
um you've chosen
um the possible return well it is coming
back
uh of friends inside the daily express
friends reunited does the world need a
friend's reunion
well well i don't know but you know it's
a date it appears that won't be moved by
kovitz so may the 27th is when
there's going to be some fresh new
episodes of friends and those of us who
are a certain generation
you know couldn't escape friends when it
seems like much longer but it was 17
years ago that the last episode it aired
but it was with us you know in our so
those of us as i say of certain age in
our
teens and 20s and it almost feels like
it never went away it's always been on
some channel somewhere
so it's it's gathered further fans in
the intervening years
uh and now all these uh uh slightly more
older and mature stars and i'm gonna
credit susie with this joke i think she
said this episode should be the one with
the botox
suzy well done none of them look you
know a week older do they
no no they difficult no the last one had
52 million viewers in the states when
they finished the last series so
there's obviously still a probably a
huge fan base and plenty of uh
advertising money to be made from coming
back
um but but i think look we all need a
bit of cheer a bit of normality so is
this a bit of
normality coming back to us uh maybe
it's a good thing and uh i'll probably
tune in
okay well thanks so much for bringing us
your choices this half hour we'll get a
lot more from you at 11 30. susie
boniface and cool via ranger thank you
both very much
just to say that if you missed any of
the press preview tonight it is
available
shortly and every night on our youtube
channel